- Antonio,
- Antonio.
- [Man] Tell him what
you said you remember.
- I remember that you say you don't give
about what people say.
- That's right.
You remember that, man, and
life can get really good
for a long time.
(bass music)
(bright acoustic music)
You need to look real sharp.
(laughs)
A real CEO.
The thing that's running through
my mind most this morning
is how humbled I am to be
associated with these two,
how humbled I am that you
guys are here this morning.
I think we are on the verge
of fundamentally shifting
the entire industry.
Not because of what Resy
does for the consumer
and the restaurateur, but for
where it has taken the mark
for everybody within the ecosystem.
I'm convinced after today's
presentation that many
in this room and many
acquaintances and friends of people
in this room will go back
and look at all forms
of their technology or execution,
and strive for the higher plane.
Everything I've done in the wine business
and the advertising world,
we've made a nice impact,
but the thing that has
made me most exciting
is that we'd impacted others
to take the bar higher.
No question, there's nothing
that I'm associating with that is raising
the collective in the
entire space more than what
the Resy team is doing for this industry.
This feels nice.
Vlad, listen to me.
You have one at bat, this
crisp clean beautiful day.
We just got positive
vibes, me and D-Rock here.
And it's interesting, I literally
through that positive vibe
in this little chilly walk to the car,
fundamentally know that my
day's gonna be better now,
just 'cause of that
positive reinforcement.
It's so weird for me how
much I hate to be thought of
as a motivational speaker.
It's also so weird for me how
obvious it is that optimism
and kindness are foundational
pieces to a happy,
executable life, career, winning.
Please just cut out the
cancer and negativity,
please cut out complaining,
please cut out negative
and inject positive.
Cut out negative people,
cut out negative thoughts,
go see somebody, write
a blog post about it,
get it out of your system, the negativity,
get it out of your system,
and instill positivity.
It's obvious out here.
(cinematic music)
Guys, while I've got you,
we're getting really close.
I don't know if you can taste it.
You know, everybody has a
different VaynerMedia, right?
You're in your own little
sectors, doing your own things.
I'm telling you right
now, we're awfully close.
It's getting really scary out here,
meaning we're gonna win this whole thing.
I fundamentally believe it's over.
I always kinda thought
that, but man oh man oh man.
We are very close to being
the dominant communications
agency in North America for sure,
and Alan and Jeff Nicholson
are in Singapore right now
on the call, getting very real.
Please, please, please, if that
is not your drop-dead belief
schedule some time with me
so I can educate you on the reality.
Thank you.
- [Woman] Thanks everyone.
- [Man] Beth, it's so good to see you.
- Hey, thanks for seeing me!
- Sorry to make you wait.
- No, that's all right,
it's good to see you.
How are you doing?
- So good to see you.
Hey gang!
Hi, hi.
How's everybody?
- [Woman] Good.
- [Gary] How's everybody's morning?
- [Male] Good, how are you?
- [Gary] Good, good.
- [Female] Good, how are you?
I like your kicks.
- Thanks, yeah, K-Swiss is now
inspired to make cool stuff
since Gary Vee sold him
some pairs of sneakers.
(laughs)
(uplifting music)
I've been thinking a lot lately about
life, to be honest and lately, I'm sure,
for especially the most
hard-core who follow me,
for the last couple months
I've been talking about
aspiring to be the best
entrepreneur of this generation
or the entrepreneur of this generation.
A lot of it obviously comes
with business success, right?
But to be very frank,
outside of me falling ill
or the seven to 10 people
I care about the most
falling ill, at this point, VaynerX,
the holding company,
Vayner Media and PureWow
and all new the stuff were launching,
it's going to be a billion dollar company,
it's just the truth.
I mean, it is what it fucking is.
It's fucking, it's a wrap.
But to be in the breath
of all these incredible entrepreneurs
that are really changing the game,
and, you know, inspiring people
like an Elon Musk or what have you,
I think to be the best
entrepreneur of this generation,
you're gonna have to
not only build the
incredible all time business,
and an impact in your industry,
or in industries like I'm aspiring to,
but you also have to bring the most value
to the other entrepreneurs
that are behind you
or parallel to you or above you.
I genuinely believe that I
won't inspire that many people
with the kind of businesses I built.
It's just not me, I'm not
gonna invent Uber or Facebook,
a Skim or anything.
You know, I'm not gonna do that.
But nobody's gonna try
harder to bring more value
to the masses, through their content,
through their actions,
through their one-on-one engagements,
through their rand,
I mean, I did a random phone call,
I've slid into like 50 accounts right now
my Instagram 'cause I put a post up.
Put it right here, dude.
And then the stuff that I'm about to do.
I'm in that place right now
where my ambitions are getting greater.
Gonna take advantage of me
being in a thoughtful mode.
You know, while I'm not at my most hyped.
Not my most hyped, my normal.
While I'm not in my normal,
I just really wanna
speak right to the camera
and make it very perfectly clear,
it's the practicality,
it's the dirty stuff
that really matters.
It's the practicality,
it's the putting on the
pants and doing your thing.
It's the actions that are
really gonna determine
what happens, so, just a whole
lot of talking in the system.
I talk a lot about, "Do your
actions match your ambition?"
So many of you are so accustomed
to consuming my content
on full hype, wrestling promo mode,
maybe this tone will break through.
It doesn't matter what you say,
it doesn't matter what
everybody else says,
it matters what you're gonna do.
Just remember you have
lot of time to do it,
a lot more than you think.
So go do it.
- [Man] Good to see you.
- Good to see you, thanks for having me.
- Thank you for meeting me.
- So everybody, please, give
me a huge round of applause
for my friend Gary Vee.
(applauding)
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Thanks for having me.
- [Woman] Thank you.
- It's really hard for me
to worry about anybody in this room
when you're in the first inning,
when you're in the first quarter.
What happens in the first 20 years
of your life means nothing.
Means nothing.
I think your adversity is your gift.
Straight up.
Because what you don't realize
is happening right now in the world
is the internet is making everything equal
and the chip on the shoulder
that's forming on you right now
the fact that you're not
entitled and you're not soft
and you can appreciate shit,
that's gonna play out in
your 20s, 30s and 40s.
You don't see it now,
but you're gonna look
at it the same way I did
when I was nine and my
mom said go yourself
buy your own Nintendo.
(laughs)
I hated life.
Now it's the best that
ever happened to me.
When I was 13 and I had
to work every weekend
and make two bucks an hour bagging ice
for 15 hours a day and all
my friends were partying,
hooking up and having fun
and going to parties and.
I hated it.
Now it's the best that
every happened to me.
So, while everybody was
looking down at me back then,
I was looking inside my own head.
And honestly, every time
anybody looked down at me,
I registered that and put it in a column
and that became my fuel.
So, I think you're lucky.
And I know you don't,
but just remember in 20
or 30 years this talk
because I think you might agree.
If you're willing to put in the work.
- Me, I want to become an author and.
- [Gary] Okay.
- (mumbles) just like you.
- [Gary] Amazing.
- And I have been writing, it's my passion
and I had applied to
this writing on YCteen,
and I spilled my heart
out, it was just me,
just me words.
- Raw.
- Yes, they declined me.
So, it's like, that's me.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- So it's like they're not accepting me.
- [Gary] Them.
- But it's like, should I.
(laughs)
- Honestly, guys, first of all,
they didn't decline you.
One random person that read
your declined you, them.
- [Girl] Imagine if I
changed some stuff up,
if I'd change me, they
woulda probably took me.
- You're wrong, you're wrong.
Listen to my face.
I'm telling you right to
your face, you're wrong.
You're valuing somebody
else's opinion too much.
You're wrong.
I'm just telling.
This is not a debate, you're wrong.
You understand?
- Okay.
- You're letting one random person.
Listen, do you understand how
many people would've hired me?
- Mhmm.
- None
- Oh, okay.
(laughs)
- Who's got Instagram in here?
Cool, go to it right now, please.
Do me a huge favor.
Go to Instagram, go to Gary
V-E-E, that's my account.
Go 10, 11 posts back,
you'll see my report card.
I was ranked 243rd out of 254 in my class.
243 outta 254 in my class, you know why?
Because I knew it was for me.
It might not be bullshit for you,
this is about self-awareness.
You have to know who the you are.
But for me, it was
'cause I didn't need it.
I didn't give a about Saturn,
how many rings Saturn had.
Listen to me.
You can't let something
be valuable more than.
You're pandering to them.
Let them come to you.
Take that same essay and
post that on Instagram
with a photo and see what happens.
- [Girl] On my Facebook.
- See what happens.
Let the market decide,
not some middle management
person that read your.
- [Girl] Okay.
- Good.
Of course it's true.
And when you're young
and 13 and 15 and nine,
you think you gotta change your up
because you don't know how it's played.
That's why I'm here, to tell
you exactly how it's played.
One person read your story, my dear.
And that person.
- [Girl] Okay.
- I'm glad you asked your question.
- [Girl] Yes, me too.
- Always remember that, please.
- [Girl] Yes, I will.
- Please.
- I will.
- Good.
(laughs)
- Antonio.
- [Man] Tell him what
you said you remember.
- I remember that you say you don't give
a about what other people say.
- That's right.
You remember that, man?
And life can get really
good for a long time.
Take care, Antonio.
(uplifting music)